[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياط في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
البدايه من واشنطن وتحديدا البيت الابيض
من هناك يتحدث منسق العلاقات الاستراتيجيه
بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي للجزيره بعد
قليل عن تفاصيل اتفاق مع ايران تم بموجبه
اخراجه خمسه محتجزين امريكيين من السجن
ووضعهم تحت الاقامه الجبريه
[موسيقى]
تاخذنا الصور المباشره ايضا الى طهران حيث
قال كبير المفاودين الايرانيين علي باقر
انه قد تم بدء عمليه الافراج عن مليارات
الدولارات من اموال طهران بعد سنوات من
احتجازها بشكل غير قانوني حسب تعبيره
ثم الى ابو جا واقتتام قمه استثنائيه
لمجموعه ايكواس تم الاعلان فيها عن
التاكيد على الخيارات السلميه لاستعاده
النظام الدستوري في النيجر
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
صفقه امريكيه ايرانيه لاطلاق سراح محتجزين
امريكيين مقابل سجناء ايرانيين والغاء
تجميد سته مليار دولار من عائدات النفط
الايراني مصدر ايراني مطلع يؤكد للجزيره
ان الاتفاق خطوه اوليه يليها ايداع
الاموال المجمده بحسابات خاصه في قطر
لمراقبه استخدامها ومسؤولون غربيون يقولون
ان وساطه قطريه نجحت في تسهيل الصفقه
جونكر يتحدث للجزيره عن تفاصيل الاتفاق
ومستقبل العلاقه مع ايران في ضوء ابرامه
في ختام قمتها الاستثنائيه تؤكد على
الخيارات السلميه لاستعاده النظام
الدستوري في النيجر
وتقرر في الوقت ذاته تفعيل قواتها
الاحتياطيه
الانقلاب يتحدون الضغوط الدوليه بتنصيب
حكومه جديده
ومسؤولون غربيون ينقلون عنهم التهديد بقتل
الرئيس المحتجز اذا تدخل الجوار عسكريا
[موسيقى]
وسط تقارير عن تعثر في مسار الهجوم المضاد
الجيش الاوكراني يقر بصعوبات في جبهات
الشماليه والشرقيه
ويبدا اخلاء بلدات في مقاطعه مع اعلان
الجيش الروسي تعزيز مواقعه هناك وفي
واشنطن اداره بايدن تتجه لتقديم مساعدات
دفاعيه طارئه
بثلاثه عشر مليار دولار
الجيش السوداني يساعد هجماته على الدعم
السريع في مدن العاصمه الثلاث الطائرات
الحربيه تغير على تجمعات لقوات الدعم في
شرق الخرطوم وبحري والجانب يتبادلان القصف
المدفعي في ام درمان وسط نزوح للمدنيين
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم التداعيات
المحتمله للاعلان التونسي الليبي بشان
التوافق على حل لازمه طالبي اللجوء
العالقين على الحدود لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي برايكم الى اي درجه ينهي الاتفاق
التونسي الليبي ماساه طالبي اللجوء على
الحدود بين البلدين جاءت الاجابات على
النحو التالي
18% قالوا ان الدرجه كبيره بينما صوت نحو
26% لصالح القول ان درجه انهاء الاتفاق
محدوده اخيرا قال سته وخمسون في المئه ان
الاتفاق لا ينهي الازمه اطلاقا هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار
الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميه
تطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده عربيا وكذلك
دوليا
ولا تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
[موسيقى]
لقاء خاص مع ثمن باور مديره الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه تتحدث للجزيره
عن ازمه الحبوب الاوكرانيه ومصير
المساعدات الامريكيه للنيجر
[موسيقى]
قالت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه انه بدا
الافراج عن مبلغ من اموال طهران المجمده
في احد البنوك الاوروبيه وكشفت الوكاله ان
الاتفاق مع واشنطن يشمل الافراج عن عشره
مليارات دولار في كوريا الجنوبيه والعراق
واوضحت انه سيتم الافراج عن اموال ايرانيه
من بنك التجاره العراقي ضمن الصفقه مع
واشنطن وسيتم نقل الاموال المجمده من
كوريا الجنوبيه الى سويسرا قبل تحويلها
الى قطر وحسب وكاله الانباء الايرانيه فان
الاتفاق مع واشنطن يشمل الافراج عن خمسه
سجناء من كل طرف
هذا وقال مصدر ايراني مطلع للجزيره ان
الخطوه القادمه تتلخص في ايداع الاموال
المجمده في حسابات خاصه بدوله قطر واصف
اياها بالعمليه المعقده مشددا على ان
الافراج النهائي عن السجناء الامريكيين
مرهون بايداع الاموال الايرانيه في حسابات
خاصه بدوله قطر
من جهته اكد البيت الابيض نقل امريكيين من
السجن الى الاقامه الجبريه في ايران ووصف
الخطوه بالمشجعه بينما نقلت صحيفه عن
مسؤولين امريكيين ان واشنطن تامل تؤدي
العمليه في نهايه المطاف الى عوده
المحتجزين وتهيئه الظروف لاحراز تقدم في
المحادثات بشان البرنامج النووي واضافت
الصحيفه ان عوده السجناء الى الولايات
المتحده يمكن ان تحدث بمجرد افراج واشنطن
عن 6 مليارات دولار من عائله النفط
الايراني المجمده في كوريا الجنوبيه ولفتت
فاين شو تايمز الى انه اذا تم الافراج عن
الاموال الايرانيه فسيتم نقلها الى حساب
في دوله قطر حيث ستتم مراقبتها للتاكد من
استخدامها فقط في المجالات غير الخاضعه
للعقوبات مثل الدواء والغذاء وقالت ان قطر
احدى الدول القليله التي تت او بعلاقات
جيده مع واشنطن وطهران وساعدت في تسهيل
المحادثات بشان اطلاق السجناء
للمزيد عن الاموال الايرانيه المجمده واين
تتوزع وكم ستحصل عليه الخزينه الايرانيه
في حال منحت واشنطن الضوء الاخضر نتابع
تقرير التالي
يعد ملف الاموال الايرانيه المجمده في
الخارج بفعل العقوبات الامريكيه واحدا من
اهم القضايا العالقه بين ايران والولايات
المتحده واي تحرك بشانه يعد اشاره الى ان
شيئا ما يحصل بين واشنطن وطهران في يونيو
الماضي افرج العراق عن نحو مليارين
وسبعمائه مليون دولار من الاموال
الايرانيه المجمده بعد التوصل الى تفاهم
بين بغداد وواشنطن اثر لقاء جمع وزيري
خارجيتي البلدين
وسبق لوسائل اعلام ايرانيه ان تحدثت عن
قرب الافراج عن نحو 24 مليارا من الاموال
المجمده في الخارج خصوصا تلك الموجوده لدى
العراق والبالغه عشره مليارات دولار اضافه
الى اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه فضلا عن
مستحقات لايران لدى البنك الدولي تقدر
بحوالي سته مليارات و700 مليون دولار
وكانت بريطانيا افرجت في مارس 2022 عن
خمسمائه وثلاثين مليون دولار بعد اخراج
ايران عن الصحفيه البريطانيه من اصل
ايراني نازلين وفي العام نفسه اخرج العراق
عن مليار وستمائه مليون دولار خصصت لسداد
ديون المستحقه على بغداد مقابل مستورداتها
من الكهرباء الايرانيه في حين تشير ارقام
غير رسميه الى وجود ما بين 22
مليار دولار مجمده في الصين وهي اموال
ايرانيه نقلت من دول اخرى لبيجين ولا يمكن
تحويلها الى ايران بسبب العقوبات
الامريكيه
معنى من واشنطن
وكبير الباحثين في معهد صوفان للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والامن الدولي والمستشار
السابق في الكونغرس لشؤون ايران والخليج
العربي
ومن طهران علي اكبر داريني الباحث المتخصص
في الدراسات الايرانيه الامريكيه اهلا
بكما ضيفيه الكاريب بضيف من واشنطن السيد
السيد كاساله عن
العوامل التي ساعدت في انجاز هذه الصفقه
لماذا الان
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه الكريمه
ونحن نتحدث عن عمليه كان نقاش بشانها
لفتره طويله وهناك مفاوضات وهذا ما اعلن
عنه الجانب الامريكي لم يتحدث عن انجازها
ولكن يبدو اننا وصلنا الى المراحل الاخريه
خصوصا الاخيره عفوا خصوصا اذا ما تم اطلاق
سراح الامريكيين من السجون اذا نتحدث عن
عمليه بدات منذ فتره طويله نتحدث عن عمليه
محدوده اذن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ايضا
لديها قدرات من طائرات وحاملات طائرات
ربما طهران حصلت على رساله وصلتها رساله
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عازمه في
ردع لايران وهذه المفاوضات بدات منذ اشهر
ولربما طهران قررت ان الاوان قد
القيام بهذا الاتفاق لتخفيف من الضغط على
طهران وطهران تعرف انه لا يمكنها ان تعتمد
على روسيا ظنت ايران انا لديها علاقه
استراتيجيه او شراكه استراتيجيه مع روسيا
ولكن روسيا ايضا تبتعد عن ايران قليلا
لانها تود ان تتعامل مع دول الخليجيه
الاخرى لربما هناك توتر في ايران
وشعروا انه يتعين عليهم ان يقوموا بهذه
الصفقه لتخفيف من الضغط على النظام في
طهران ذات السؤال اساله اكبر داريني عن
العوامل التي حسمت وكانت حاسمه في توقيع
هذه الصفقه اخيرا
مع السيد هذه الصفقه بدات منذ اشهر ولكنني
لا اتفق معه بالنسبه الى الاسباب الامر لا
يتعلق بالتعزيزات العسكريه الامريكيه
الاخيره في منطقه الخليج هذه الصفقه لم
تتم بشكل كامل بعد ولكن كان بالامكان ان
تبرم الشهر الماضي او العام الماضي ولكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اوقفت كل
الجهود بسبب اعمال الشغب التي اندلعت في
ايران بالاضافه الى الاولويات في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
وهي زرع التوترات في ايران وكانت تلك
الاولويه الامريكيه ولكن الان وقد انتهينا
من اعمال الشغب في ايران الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ابدت عن
جاهزيتها واستعداداتها للدخول في المسار
الدبلوماسيه مجددا باشارتك للمساره
الدبلوماسيه من واشنطن عن تاثير الاتفاق
على هذه الصفقه على مجمل المسار الامريكي
الايراني حتى في ملفات اخرى باعتقادك
نحن نتحدث عن تاثير محدود للغايه
اذا هناك
اقتصاد يعاني في ايران وهو لم ينمو بشكل
كبير
اذا حتى بعد توقف
المفاوضات بشان الاتفاق النووي هذه
المليارات السته لن تبقى لفتره طويله هناك
حاجه لشراء الادويه
وهناك ايضا حاجه الى المساعدات للاقتصاد
الايراني ولكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لن تخفض من عقوباتها على ايران ايران لن
تتمكن من بيع نفطها ولن تتمكن من
الطبيعه النفط وتحصل على العائدات ايذاء
النفط الايراني
لا ارى ان هذا الاتفاق يغير المعادله بشكل
كبير نعم كان بالامكان التوصل الى الاتفاق
منذ سنه ولكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لم تود ان تعود الى الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران وايران كانت تود ان تربط هذا
الموضوع بالملفات المرتبطه ايضا بالوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه ادبيه الولايات المتحده لم
تقدم التنازلات بشان ذلك وبالتالي بالنسبه
الى التبادل السجناء هذا موضوع منفصل
وايضا بالنسبه الى الاصول الايرانيه في
كوريا الجنوبيه هذا امر منفصل ولكن ما من
تفاهمات مرتبطه بالجانب النووي بالنسبه
الى هذه الصفقه سيدي علي اكبر كيف ترى
ايران الى هذه الصفقه
والصيغه التي جاءت بها
سيد علي اكبر
سالتك كيف ترى ايران في انجاز هذه الصفقه
هناك مشكله في الصوت مع ضيفنا من طهران
اعود الى ضيفي السيد الان يسمع الرضي في
منتهى السيد علي اكبر سالته عن كيف تنظر
ايران الى هذه الصفقه في هذا التوقيت
نحن نتحدث عن استعاده للمسار الدبلوماسي
وانا ارى ذلك على انه جهد جديد
للمباشره بالمسار الدبلوماسي بعدما فشلت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من تحقيق
اهدافها من خلال زعزعه الاستقرار او
محاوله زعزعه الاستقرار واثاره الشغب
والقلاقل في ايران وبالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
توتر برز في الاشهر الماضيه بين ايران
والولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده لجات
الى القرصنه في البحار واحتجزت ناقله
النفط الايرانيه في خلال ساعات النهار
وبالتالي يمكن النظر الى هذه الصفقه على
انها محاوله من كلا الطرفين لخفض التصعيد
في وجود تصعيد متزايد ومؤشرات في المنطقه
في هذا الاتجاه وفي الوقت نفسه طهران
الى هذه الصفقه على انها جهد لا يؤدي الى
تقديمي تنازلات كبرى وفي الوقت نفسه يساعد
هذا الجهد على خفض التصعيد رايتك
تمتعرض وترفض بعد تصريحات ضيفي من طهران
ولكن اسالك ايضا ان كان ما تم في هذه
الصفقه
يرجح لدى واشنطن مساله القنوات والحوار
الدبلوماسي بدلا من استعراض العضلات كما
يقول ضيفي من طهران
في الحقيقه اذا الضيف في طهران يدعي ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي من اثارت
اعمال الشغب ولكن اعمال الشغب بحسب معرفه
بدات منذ سنه لان نظام الايراني قام
بتوقيف امراه لانها لم ترتدي الحجاب بشكل
مناسب الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تطلب
من السيده لا ترتدي الحجاب والولايات
المتحده لم تطلب من الشرطه الايرانيه ان
تحتجز المراه وان تموت قيد الاحتجاز
وبالتالي القول ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لديها دور في هذه الاعمال اعمال
الشغب هذا بالفعل امر لا يصدق ولكن
بالنسبه الي اذا ما كنت اقدم المشهوره
للمرشد الاعلى كنت لا انصحه بان لا يحاول
ان يهاجم السفن التجاريه في منطقه الخليج
مجددا وانصحه بشده لان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اظهرت عن عزمها لمنع ايران من
القيام بذلك واذا ما حاولت ايران ان تحتجز
الصفا وناقلات النفط مجددا ايران سوف تاسف
شديد اسف بسبب قراره ابقى معك هل يمكن
البناء على ما تم في هذا الاتفاق من اجل
اعطاء اولويه اكثر
للمحادثات للقاءات الدبلوماسيه حتى وان
كان عبر قنوات اخرى
هناك دائما فرص متاحه للدبلوماسيه وكان
هناك مباحثات كما نعرف لاحياء خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه المعروفه الا وهي
الاتفاق النووي سنه ونصف من المباحثات
التي اقتربت كثيرا من الاتفاق ولكن ايران
اصرت على ان الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه يتعين عليها ان تتوقف في
تحقيقاتها بنسبه الى الاثار النوويه في
بعض المواقع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لم توافق على ذلك اذا ما غيرت ايران في
موقفها ولربما توافق على ذلك لربما نرى
فرصه من اجل المسار الدبلوماسي ولكننا
الان نقترب من الانتخابات الامريكيه في
العام المقبل والسلطات الايرانيه في الوقت
نفسه تود ان تتاكد من انه اذا ما لم يعاد
انتخاب الرئيس بايدن الرئيس التالي
للولايات المتحده الام سوف
يوافق على الاتفاق النووي ولكن الرئيس
بايدن لا يمكنه ان يتقدم بتعهد مماثل بحسب
القوانين الامريكيه لذلك ايران لا تود ان
تفكك البرنامج النووي مجددا لترى لربما ان
الولايات المتحده تنسحب من الاتفاق بعد
الانتخابات المقبله ايضا نتحدث عن مسائل
شائكه لا يمكن ان تحل قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في الولايات المتحده من طهران
هذه ليست اول صفقه تتعلق بالسجناء بين
واشنطن ولكن ما الذي يميز هذه الصفقه هذه
المره
الذي يميز هذه الاتفاقيه او هذه الصفقه هو
التوقيت كما سبق واسلفت نحن نتحدث عما
يبدو على انه جهد من قبل طهران و واشنطن
لخفض
التوتر ونزع فتيل التوتر الذي برز في
المنطقه منذ اشهر وانا اتفاجا لماذا السيد
كاتمان لماذا لا ينصح اداره بايدن لا تلجا
الى القرصنه في البحار في المقام الاول
ويطلب من ايران الا ترد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه احتجزت ناقله نفط ايرانيه في
خرق فاضحا للقوانين الدوليه في البحار
والسيد كاتمان لم يشجع
الاداره الامريكيه التي تتصرف
كقراصنه وفي الوقت نفسه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
شنت ارهابا اقتصاديا تجاه ايران واداره
بايدن استمرت في نفس النهج الذي بداه
الرئيس السابق ترامب الحمله حمله الضغط
الاقصى استمرت مع اداره بايدن كان
بالامكان ان تغير اداره بايدن في هذه
المقاربه وان ترفع العقوبات منذ اليوم
الاول منذ العشرين من يناير كانون الثاني
2021 وبالتالي بسبب هذه التوترات يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده وايران تظهران بعض
الاهتمام باستعاده العمل على المسار
الدبلوماسي من اجل التمكن من احتواء هذه
التوترات واداره التوتر على مدى سنوات بني
جدار من عدم الثقه بين واشنطن وطهران
توقيع صفقه من هذا القبيل الا يحدث ولو
فتحه ولو صغيره في هذا الجدار
في الحقيقه ما لم نتحدث عنه بعد هو ان
ايران هي التي استحدثت
انعدام الثقه من خلال بيع المسيرات للسيد
توتن وبالتالي ان المرشد الاعلى هو شخصا
مثقف وهو شخصا بارز كان يجب ان يفهم نقطه
اساسيه هو هي انه عندما
الخلاف وعدم الثقه الامريكي الايراني ابعد
كثيرا من الازمه في اوكرانيا
نعم اتفق معك ولكن ايران صعدت من خلال بيع
هذه المسيرات للسيد توتن وبالتالي هي دخلت
على الخط وانحازت الى توتن والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في المقابل تساعد
اوكرانيا لكي تلحق الهزيمه واوضحت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان السيد
بوتين سوف يهزم بالفعل وان الموقف
الايراني الى جانب روسيا حشرها في موقف
صعب امام الولايات المتحده واوروبا اوروبا
لا تدعم التنازلات مع طهران الان بسبب بيع
طهران لهذه المسيرات لروسيا اكبر اذا ما
تمت وتم انجاز هذه الصفقه كامله
بكامل بنودها باعتقادك الى ماذا يمكن ان
تؤسس على صعيد بقيه الملفات بين واشنطن
وطهران
تم تنفيذ الصفقه بحسب ما اتفق عليه من شان
ذلك ان يفسح في المجال امام اتفاقيات
شفهيه ايضا في المستقبل يتعين علينا ان
نكون واضحين ما من اتفاق رسميا بين ايران
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه اذن
انتهى العمل بها وهناك امال محدوده
باحيائها وبالتالي في غياب المفاوضات
لاحياء خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه اتفق
الطرفان على التوصل الى اليات وترتيبات
غير رسميه شفهيه لكي تتمكن اداره بايدن من
ان تتفادى بان تبدو بمظهر الاداره التي
تقدم التنازلات الجامه لايران والامر
بالنسبه الى ايران في داخل الايرانيه ولكن
في حال طبق هذا الاتفاق هذا يعني ان كلا
الطرفين عادى الى الدبلوماسيه ويفسح ذلك
في المجال امام حلله ممكنه في الملف في
النووي والذي على اساسه يمكن ان
الوقت ضيفي من طهران علي اكبر الباحث
المتخصص في الدراسات الايرانيه الامريكيه
وكذلك ضيفي من واشنطن
الكبيره الباحثين في معهد صوفان للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والامن الدولي والمستشار
السابق في الكونغرس لشؤون الامن بعد ايضا
من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه وكذلك
من واشنطن علي واعظ مدير مشروع ايران في
مجموعه الازمات الدوليه اهلا بكم ابدا
بالدكتور خليل كيف وج دت هذا الاتفاق وما
توفر حوله من معلومات حتى الان
انا اعتقد هذا كان امر متوقع لحد ما خاصه
في ظل وجود مفاوضات على مدار عامين
متواصلين فيما يتعلق باطلاق سراح عدد من
المحتجزين الامريكيين من اصول ايرانيه
بعضهم محتاجه لسنوات بعضهم خلال الفتره
الماضيه وهذا طبعا جاء يعني جزء منه
مفاجاه متعلق انه كان هناك التعاثر بشكل
او باخر فيما يتعلق بامكانيه اتمام
الاتفاق النووي الايراني اللي تم الانسحاب
منه من قبل ترامب 2018 وفي نفس الوقت ايضا
وجود توترات كما راينا على مدار اخر كم
يوم فيما يتعلق اولا بامكانيه ارسال
امريكا لجنود المشاه لوضعهم على نقلات
تجاريه خوفا من وجود نوع من القرصنه
الايرانيه او الاحتجاز الايراني لهم كما
جاء في الاخبار قبل عده ايام وفي نفس
الوقت كمان وجود مناورات عسكريه ايرانيه
بحريه في الخليج العربي باستخدام صواريخ
يصل المذاهي الاكثر من 500 كلم كان عمل
التوتر وبالتالي على ما يبدو انه خلف
الكاولي كان هناك مفاوض قامت بها دول
متعدده من ضمنهم مثلا عمان وقطر وسويسرا
نتج عنها بشكل او باخر هذا الامر وهذا
يعتبر في جزء منه متعلق بالتسويق السياسي
لبيضن جزء من الصفقه متعلق بارضاء القاعده
الانتخابيه لبيض خاصه فيما يتعلق بالحزب
الديمقراطي نحن مقبلون بشكل او باخر على
موسم انتخابي خلال الفتره المقبله
وبالتالي قد يتم استخدامها
كنوع من الترويج له ولكن عليه باب من
الانتقادات الكثيره من قبل الجمهوريين
لانه هذا الامر ايضا حدث قبل حوالي سبعه
عوامل عندما قام اوباما ايضا باعطاء ما
يقرب من حوالي مليار و300 مليون مقابل
اطلاق صلاح امريكي فكان هناك نوع من
الانتقاد الشديد له من قبل الجمهوريين في
الكون الامريكي ماذا حقق كل طرف بتوقيع
هذه الصفقه الامريكيه والايراني باعتقادك
نحن نتحدث عن اول اتفاق دبلوماسي بين
ايران واداره بايدن في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولذلك نحن نتحدث عن نقطه في
غايه الاهميه ويمكن ان تعبد الطريق امام
انخراطا دبلوماسيا اضافيا من كلا الطرفين
لحل المعضلات وفي الوقت نفسه هناك بعض
الفتره الزمنيه بين وضع السجناء قيد
الاقامه الجبريه والوقت الذي يمكن ان
يغادروا البلاد فيه وبالنظر الى مستوى
التوتر بين الطرفين امل ان الامور سوف
تسير على خير ما يرام وان تنفذ الصفقه
بالفعل وهنا اسال الدكتور خليل العذاري
فيما يتعلق بهذه الخطوه وانعكاساتها على
بقيه الملفات الاخرى
العالقه والشائكه وهذه المراوحه بين
التوتر عالي الشده وبين هذه الفرص او
الفسحه لحدوث اتفاق بين طرفين
انا اعتقد يا صاحبي القادر من الصعب ان
نربط بين الامرين بمعنى اخر لابد ان نفرق
بين ملفات المتعدده بين ايران وبين امريكا
فيما يتعلق بملف السجناء الامريكيين اصول
الايرانيه هناك هذا ملف مهم جدا خاصه كما
قلت قبل قليل بالنسبه لاداره بيض المحليه
وداخليا وفي نفس الوقت مهم جدا لارى لانه
يسمح لها بشكل واخر بالحصول على مبالغ
ماليه كبيره جدا تصل حوالي سته مليار
دولار حسب بعض التقارير الاخباريه قد
تساعد في حل الازمه الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه
الموجوده على مدار اخر كم سنه وبالتالي
مكسب للطرفين لكن ايضا من الصعب جدا القول
بانه هذه قد تمثل اختراق او تمهيد للتواصل
اتفاقنا وايراني هذا امر مختلف تمام لماذا
عده عوامل العامل الاول انه حتى هذه
اللحظه هناك مشاكل فنيه ما بين ايران من
جهه والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الدائريه من
جهه اخرى الامر الثاني متعلق بطول
الاسرائيلي او الفزاعه الاسرائيليه او
اسرائيل لن تسمح في رايي الشخصي بوجود
اتفاق نووي ايراني لا ياخذ على الاقل في
الاعتبار امكانيه ان تقوم اسرائيل في وقت
من الاوقات اربع عسكريه لايران وبيؤكد
كلامي انه احنا قرانا في الاخبار اخر سبع
ثمان شهور ان هناك خطه امريكيه سريه
ومناورات عسكريه امريكيه اسرائيليه تحاكي
امكانيه توجيه ضربات عسكريه للمفاعلات
النووي الايرانيه وبالتالي الخيار العسكري
موجود على الطاوله الامريكيه حتى هذه
اللحظه في نفس الوقت ايضا على ما يبدو ان
هناك معارضه جمهوريه قويه لاي اتفاق قد
يحدث مع ايران خاصه مثلا عندما نسمع انه
تم ازاحه واحد من اهم المفوضين الامريكيين
وهو روبوت مالي لتم تم عزل قبل اسابيعك
قليله من ملف اتفقنا انه مع ايران هذا
مؤشر ايضا على وجود يعني نوع من الرفض
لوجود تفاوض او وجود مرونه في التفاوض
الامريكي اعتقد جزء منه امريكا وبالتالي
من الصعب ان اتوقع وجود ربط بين الامرين
هذه ملفات مختلفه بعدها تقاطع احيانا
بعضها ينفصل لكنه من الصعب توقع حدوث
اختراق فيما يتعلق بنواه الايرانيه على
الاقل في الاسابيع المقبله طيب ايضا
بالتركيز على هذه الصفقه وعن
العوامل المحيطه بها هناك حديث عن الاطراف
تحديدا الطرف القطري الذي كان طبعا دكتور
خليل الذي كان مسالما في الوصول الى هذه
الصفقه ماذا عن هذا البعد وما قد يلعبه
ايضا في دائره اوسع
انا اعتقد هذا بعد مهم جدا عبد القادر
لماذا لانه ليس هناك دول كثيره لدي علاقات
طيبه مع كلا الدولتين
علاقات جيده الحد بعيد مع ايران في نفس
الوقت حليف مهم جدا لامريكا وبالتالي تلعب
دور مهم
المواقف وفي تقليب واعتقد انه لعب الدور
مهم قبل فتره لم يدخل له النجاح فيما
يتعلقنا وايراني لكنه انا اعتقد انه في
هذه المرحله تحديدا بنتكلم على دور حيوي
جدا بدات بعمان ثم استكملته ايران يعني
عفوا قطر يعني مثلا فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق
الذي حدث اليوم الذي يعني قد يتم مقبله
نتكلم على انه سوف يتم ايداع ما يكن من 6
مليار دولار من كوريا الجنوبيه في بنوك
قطريه ولن يسمح لايران بالحصول على اموال
بشكل مباشر ستحصل عليها من خلال قطر وبال
تقوم بارسال الاموال الى ايران خاصه فيما
يتعلق بامراض رئيسين بالصرف على الغذاء
وعلى الدواء وامريكا لديها شرط مهم وهي
اعتاد ان تضمن الا يتم استخدام هذه
الاموال المجمده التي يتم الافراج عنها في
امور عسكريه او في تقويه السلاح الاسلحه
الباليستيه الايرانيه وبالتالي
تلعب دور مهم جدا في ضمان نجاح هذه الصفقه
واعتقد انه خلال فتره المقبله قد نشت دور
متزايدا لقطر فيما يتعلق بامكانيه العوده
اطلاق النووي الايراني خاصه اذا كان هناك
مرونه بين الطرفين الامريكي والايراني
سيد علي واعظ ضمن سياسه العصب والجزره
المطروحه دائما بين الطرفين طبعا اعتذر
سوف ننتقل الان الى ضيفنا من البيت الابيض
جون كيربي منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي اهلا بك
والسؤال الاول على ماذا اتفقتم مع الجانب
الايراني في هذه الصفقه
الان نحن
يسعدنا ان نرى ان الامريكيين الخمسه قد
خرجوا من السجن وهم قيد الاقامه الجبريه
احدهم كان قدامه الجبريه والان اتحدث عن
اربع اشخاص اخرين في هذه الوضعيه اليوم
هذا امر جيد الا يكون في السجن ولكنهم لم
يخرجوا من ايران بعد والمفاوضات تستمر مع
الايرانيين لمحاوله اخراجه من البلاد
والعوده بهم الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هنا حيث ينتمون مع عائلاتهم
وبالتالي لن اقوم بالمفاوضات الان عبر
شاشات التلفزه نحن لا نزال في مفاوضات
ناشطه مع الايرانيين وعندما يصلون الى
الولايات المتحده بسلامه وبامان وبعد ذلك
اعتقد اننا يمكننا ان نتحدث بشكل اكبر حول
هذه المفاوضات ماذا عن الاموال الايرانيه
المجمده هل هناك رقم
مجددا لن اغوص في التفاصيل ولكن اعتقد ان
هناك بعض الالتباس هنا بالنسبه الى موضوع
فكرتي الاصول الايرانيه المجمده نحن نتحدث
عن عن الامر الذي نتحدث عنه هو حسابات
كانت اصلا من الاداره السابقه التي سمحت
لعدد من البلدان او عدد كبير من البلدان
باستيراد السلعه من ايران غير الخاضعه
للعقوبات وان توضع هذه الاموال في حسابات
يمكن ايران ان تسحب منها الاموال وقد
قاموا بذلك في الاداره السابقه قاموا بذلك
وهي لا تزال قيد الاستعمال نحن نتحدث عن
امكانيه استحداث اموال بحسابات مشابهه اذا
نفس الامر وان يتمكن الايرانيون من الوصول
اليها ولكن مجددا نحن نتحدث عن امر لا
يختلف عن كيفيه استخدام هذه الاموال حيث
انها تستخدم فقط لغايه انسانيه ما الذي
ساهم في تحقيق هذه الصفقه الان رغم
محاذيرك في كلامك قبل قليل الى غايه اتمام
هذه الصفة كما قلت سيد
لست متاكدا بالرغبتي مما حدثت به في
البدايه او المحاذير في البدايه اذا نحن
ركزنا دائما على عوده الايران الامريكيين
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعد
احتجازهم في ايران هذا تركيزه رئيس بايدن
منذ اليوم الاول في صله الرئاسه واليوم
نحن نتحدث عن خطوه ايجابيه في الاتجاه
الصحيح ولكننا لا نتحدث عن صفقه مبرمه
لذلك يتنبه او يجب ان نتنبه بنسبه الى
التصريحات العامه ولكنها نتيجه جيده خرجوا
من السجن هو يوم جيد وهذه نتيجه اشهر
واشهر من العمل المضني والدبلوماسيه
للوصول الى هذه المرحله ولكننا نتحدث عن
نقطه نقطه انطلاق وهناك الكثير من العمل
بعد مصادر الدبلوماسيه تتحدث عن دور حيوي
للجانب القطري ماذا عن هذا الدور سيد
كيربي
يمكنني ان اقول لكم في هذه المرحله اننا
ممتنون للدعم الذي نلقاه من شركائنا في
المنطقه واعتقد انني سوف اترك هذه البلدان
تتحدث عن نفسها هذه الدول تتحدث عن نفسها
وتتحدث عن الدور الذي قامت به والتي سوف
تقوم به لن اتحدث بالنيابه عن هذه البلدان
ولكننا بكل تاكيد حصلنا على مساعده لم نقم
بذلك لوحدنا ونحن ممتنون على المساعده من
المنطقه متى يمكنكم القول بان هذه الصفقه
قد تمت
انه يمكنني ان اعود اليكم في المستقبل
القريب واقول انها قد تمت وان الامريكيين
الخمسه هم في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بسلامه مع عائلتهم وبكل سعاده وسرور اعود
اليكم واتحدث عند ذاك ولكن لا اعرف المده
الزمنيه نعتقد ان هذه العمليه سوف تتطلب
اسابيع ولكن ليس باستطاعتي ان احدد عدد
الاسابيع نحن نتعامل مع ايران وبالتالي
يتعينوا علينا ان نكون براجماتيين في
مقاربتنا وحاذرين بالنسبه الى التوقعات
التي نقوم بها ولكن نامل انها خطوه
ايجابيه خطوه اولى جيده لاستكمال العمليه
ونامل ان هذه العمليه سوف تستكمل في
الاسابيع المقبله طيب ماذا عن الاطراف
الراعيه لهذه تحديدا الجانب القطري ماذا
تعاولون من هذا الجانب في الوصول الى هذه
الاهداف
في الحقيقه ان دوله قطر كانت صديقه
المميزا بالنسبه الى مجالات متعدده ونحن
نعبر عن امتناننا اذا الدعم الذي حصلناه
من حصلنا عليه من دوله قطر بالنسبه الى
هذه المفاوضات على وجه الخصوص ولكن مجددا
لا اود ان اتحدث بالنيابه عن دوله قطر
ونحن لا نتحدث عن امورنا توقعها من قطر
قطر صديق جيد لنا وساعدنا بهذه العمليه
وفي المستقبل يمكننا ان نتحدث بالتفاصيل
بشكل اكبر ولكن الان في هذه المرحله نحن
نركز على استعاده الامريكيين الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي يمكننا ان
نغوص في التفاصيل مستقبلا ولكن ليس اليوم
هل سينعكس ما حدث حتى الان لا اقول سابقى
او غيرها حتى تتم كما ذكرت سيد كيربي على
اهم الملفات بين واشنطن حتى الان ما يتعلق
بالمحادثات فيما يتعلق بملف النوويه
الايراني
الان في مباحثات مع ايران بالنسبه الى
عوده الى خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه اي
الاتفاق النووي ليس هذا على الاجنده الان
ما نتحدث مع ايران بشانه الان خصوصا من
خلال الممثلين السويسريه وشركاء في
المنطقه هو اخراج الامريكيه من ايران
وايصالهم الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
نحن نركز حول كل الانشطه المزعزعه
لاستقرار لايران في المنطقه وخصوصا دعم
الروسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا ودعم
الشبكات الارهابيه في المنطقه بالاضافه
الى التهديدات
للسفن في البحار هناك نقاط كثيره ومتعدده
بنسبه الى السلوك الايراني وسوف نستمر
بالقيام بذلك شكرا لك كنت معنا من البيت
الابيض جوكر بملصق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي اعودك
الدكتور خليل العناني استمعت ربما الى
مقاله السيد جونغ كيربي ما اهم لفت
انتباهك
اول شيء هو متعلق بانه نحن ازاء عمليه
بدات اليوم خاصه فيما يتعلق بالاعلان على
الاقل يعني بدا طبعا قبل عامين مفاوضات
شقه ومستمره وسريه نحن الان اعلان رسمي من
كلا الدولتين ايران وامريكا في مطار هذه
المساله لكن ايضا نقطه مهمه جدا انها لم
تتم بعد هذه الصفقه نحن في بدايه الصفقه
قد نكون بيت مرحله اولى كما قال هي خط ولا
باتجاه اتمام الصفقه
انا اعتقد في رايي الشخصي هي عباره عمليه
بناء للثقه بين الطرفين والقيام بمطلق
عليه اجراءات حسن الثقه او حسن لقبه
الطرفين او حسن بين الطرفين جزء منه متعلق
بامكانيه ان يتم نقل المحتجزين الخمسه
اقول المسجونين الخمسه من السجن الى ربما
اقامه جبريه ربما يكون في فندق تمهيدا اذا
تم التوصل لاتفاق شامل لهذه الصفقه وتم
يعني في نوع من الثقه بين الطرفين ان يتم
نقلهم الى امريكا لاحقا وبالتالي يمكن
الحديث عنه وجود صفقه او ضمديل كما تقال
يعني هناك صفقه مبرمه لكن نحن اتصور هذا
اول حاجه تاني حاجه متعلقه بعدم كما قلت
قبل عدم الضغط بين ملف اتفقنا من جهه وملف
المحتجزين من جهه الاخرى في ايران متعلقه
بالدور الشركاء
مصطلح الثقه الضيفي الدكتور علي واعد حتى
الان اقل ما يقال عليه افضل فعلا من قبل
المسؤولين في الدولتين هو الحذر في
التصريحات فيما يتعلق باتمام هذه
الصفقه ما تفسير ذلك دكتور علي
نعم لاننا نتحدث عن الخطوه الاولى في
عمليه
وسيروره لا تزال قائمه وفي حال صارت اي
امور شائكه في الاسابيع المقبله او اذا ما
برزت التوترات بشكل متزايد في الخليج
خصوصا بالنسبه الى ناقلات النفط كما راينا
في الاشهر الماضيه الهجمات التي استهدفت
القوات الامريكيه في المنطقه هناك الكثير
معانيه هو ان هناك الكثير من الامور التي
يمكن ان تسوء في خلال هذه الفتره وهنا مرد
الحظر طيب في هذه الحاله سيد علي ايضا
فيما يتعلق بعض التفاصيل الوارده حتى الان
فيما يتعلق بالمبالغ المجمده اطراف
ايرانيه تتكلم عن حوالي عشره مليارات من
بلوغ في كوريا الجنوبيه وفي العراق وقبل
قليل كان معنا السيد كيربي وكان حذرا جدا
في اعطاء عدم اعطاء اي رقم يتعلق بهذا
المجال الى اي مدى هذا الموضوع يلفت
الانتباه
في الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن مساله جدليه
كبيره في هذه الاتفاقيه خصوصا في واشنطن
وخصوصا في الفتره الراهنه قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه حيث اننا نتحدث عن الحزب
الجمهوري الذي قال انها فديه تدفع ولكن
يجب ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار ان الفديه لا
تدفع من قبل الشخص الذي يحتجز الرهائن وفي
هذه الحاله الحقيقه هي ان ايران هي التي
تمتلك الاموال وليس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ايران ما يسمح لها هو بالفعل ان
تتمكن من استخدام هذه الاموال العائده لها
لغايات انسانيه وشراء الادويه الى اخره
وبالتالي هناك وصول محدود لايران لهذه
الاصول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
عقوباتها تستثني
الطعام وتستثني المساعدات من ادويه لم
تتمكن ايران من الوصول الى البنوك في
كوريا الجنوبيه لان البنوك في كوريا
الجنوبيه كانت حذره وكان هناك الكثير من
الامور المرتبطه بالقطاع المصرفي في كوريا
الجنوبيه تكلمنا عن الحسابات اداره بايدن
الداخليه فيما يتعلق بهذه الصفقه وهنا
ايضا السيد علي واعظ ماذا عن الحسابات
بالنسبه للجانب الايراني الحسابات
الداخليه بابرام هذه الصفقه
انتقدوا ان
الحسابات متعدده اذا هناك حاجه من قبل
الايرانيين
استفاده من خلال دعم الاقتصاد الايراني
هذا
الاتفاق يضخ اموالا في الاقتصاد الايراني
وخصوصا بالنسبه الى العمله الصعبه التي
تفقدها ايران وادت الى تراجع قيمه العمله
الايرانيه على المستوى الداخلي وبالتالي
هذه نقطه اساسيه بالنسبه الى الشعب
الايراني اذا ان تقول ايران ان الجميع
يتعامل مع ايران ليس فقط الدول الجاره بل
ايضا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الاخرى
بالاضافه الى ذلك يمكنني ان اقول انه في
خلال في السنه والنصف المقبله التي تريد
في خلالها اداره بايدن استقرارا وتفاديا
لازمه نوويه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط خصوصا
في خضم الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا ايران
ايضا الى استقرار لان لديها انتخابات
برلمانيه وفي الاسابيع المقبله ايضا هناك
ذكرى شكرا وادركنا واعتذر منك
في مجموعه الازمات الدوليه وكذلك ضيفي من
واشنطن استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه
[موسيقى]
تطورات متلاحقه تتعلق باتفاقيه الحبوب
الاوكرانيه ومصير المساعدات الامريكيه
للنيجر الحديث عن الموقف الامريكي حيال
هذه هي التطورات تنضم الينا من واشنطن
سمنثا باور مديره الوكاله الامريكيه
للتنميه الدوليه اهلا بك السيده باور
وابدا معك لم يتعلق بموضوع اتفاقيه الحبوب
عندما علق الجانب الروسي هذه الاتفاقيه
ولم يعد منها كنت انت موجوده في اوكرانيا
ماذا عن تعليق الجانب الروسي لهذه
الاتفاقيه وتاثير ذلك على خاصه الدول في
افريقيا والدول النابيه اي التزود بالحبوب
لقد راينا تاثير اين زياده في الاسعار
بنسبه تسعه بالمئه من دون انسحابه من
الاتفاق وايضا راينا ان هنالك تفريغ
للقوات الروسيه من اجل قصف مدينه اوديسا
الميناء بالتالي راينا تدميرا للكنائس ولا
ايضا للبنى التحتيه لتصدير الحبوب وهذا
الامر سيؤثر سيكون له تاثير لدى على المدى
القصير فقط لكن على المدى الطويل باعتبار
ان اوكرانيا هي كانت سله خبز لدول مثل
لبنان مصر كينيا والصومال والدول التي
تعتمد بشكل كبير على هذه على هذه الحبوب
بالتالي انا ممتنه لرؤيه الحديث من المشط
قادم من المجتمع الدولي للتحدث عن هذا
الامر دول في الشرق الاوسط وفي دول غرب
الصحراء وايضا دول الذين اذا كان هنالك
لك حضوري في روسيا كان هناك انخفاض لعدد
الحضور لكن هؤلاء القاده قاموا ادعوا
لرئيس بوتين للعوده الى الاتفاق لان هذا
الامر مهم للدول الافريقيه وهذا الامر
ايضا مهم في مساله خفض اسعار الحبوب
تقولين تاثير قصير المدى سيده السمان ولكن
حتى الان ما يطرح من بدائل تصدير القمح
الاوكراني تبدو بانها غير فعاله وقليله
التاثير وبالتالي ما تفسير بان تاثيرها
يعني لمده قصيره وليس العالم المدى الطويل
كما ذكرتي
اذا عملنا في برامجنا في اوكرانيا مع
الامم المتحده ومع الحكومه الاوكرانيه ومع
الاوروبيين من اجل ايجاد طرق بديله لتصدير
الحبوب ومن المدهش ان هذه الطرقه عن طريق
النهر وعن طريق صقر الحديد والطرق تعمل
وناجحه في حقيقه الامر ثلاثه
للحبوب للمجتمعات التي تحتاجها حول العالم
قد تزادت بسبعه 4000 بالمئه منذ الغزو
الروسي الذي قاده بتم بالتالي غد راينا
اربعين طن متريا من الاغذيه تغادر
اوكرانيا عن طريق اطرق اخرى لكن بوتين
يعرف ذلك بالتالي ما الذي قام به بوتين
بعد الانسحبه من مبادرات البحر الاسود بدا
بقصف هذه الموانئ النهريه قواته لم تقم
بهذا الامر من قبل بالتالي في الوقت الذي
بدا فيه الابتكار الاوكراني والجهد من
ليضمن انه هنالك امكانيه لايصال حبوب
والقمح الى الاشخاص الذين يحتاجون في تلك
المرحله بدا بوتين باستهداف البنى التحتيه
الموجوده على الانهار بالتالي في مرحله ما
كل الضغط يجب ان يقع حيث يكون بمعنى من
يقوم بمهاجمه البنى التحتيه على الانهار
التي يتم استخدامها لتامين تصدير الحبوب
وفي الوقت الذي نشهد فيه تصاعدا كبيرا في
انعدام الامن الغذائي حول العالم التجاوب
مع المطالب الجانب الروسي لحتى يعود الى
هذه الاتفاقيه سيدي سمانثى
دعني اكون واضحه حول ما يسمى بالمطالب
الروسيه احدى المطالب مثلا
هي ان الاغذيه الروسيه والاسمده الروسيه
لا تخضع
للعقوبات الغربيه هذه هي الحقائق
الاغذيه الروسيه والاسمده الروسيه لا تخضع
لعقوبات الغربيه في حقيقه الامر قامت
روسيا بتصدير القمح بنسب اعلى تاريخيا
الروسيه هي لا تحتاج الى
التي تحتاجه في ذلك الوقت لكنها مهتمه
بتدمير الاقتصاد الاوكراني وروسيا لا تهتم
بان تاثير تدمير الاقتصاد الاوكراني في
حقيقه الامر هذه التاثيرات يتم الشعور بها
من قبل الدول الاكثر فقرا التي تعتمد على
صادرات القمح ودعني اكون واضحه 80% من
برامج الاغذيه العالميه من القمح في تلك
البرامج التي يتم توزيعه في اماكن مثل
الصومال وفي شمال واثيوبيا 80% من هذا
القمح من برامج برنامج الغذاء العالمي قد
اتى عبر مبادره البحر الاسود خلال السنه
الماضيه بالتالي ما يقوم به بوتين هو قطع
امكانيه الوصول لهذا لشريان الحياه الذي
يصل الى الجوعه في انحاء نذهب الى بلد اخر
والى قاره اخرى النيجر ما يجري في هذا
البلد على مختلف الصعود بما فيها ما يتعلق
بالجانب الانساني والتعاون الامريكي
النيجيري وتعليق بعض هذه المساعدات
والتعاون الامريكي مع الجانب النيج في
النيجر ما هي مقاربتكم للوضع في النيجر
سيده سمانثى
بدايه ندعني اقول ان الدبلوماسيه الحيويه
النشطه هنالك حاجه ماسه لها بالتاكيد
يحاولون ان يضغطوا من
سيطروا على السلطه هناك لكي يضغطوهم الى
اعاده البلاد الى المسار الديمقراطي
واعاده الرئيس المنتخب الديمقراطي في
مساله المقاربه الامريكيه نحن نتعاون مع
شركائنا الذين يقدمون مساعدات مهمه بضمن
مياهها حكومات مختلفه هيئات حكوميه مختلفه
نحن في الولايات المتحده نقدم مساعدات
امنيه بالغه الامير حوالي 300 مليون دولار
من المساعدات الامنيه لانه كان هنالك
تهديدات ارهابيه داخل النيجر ومن الواضح
انه عندما يكون هنالك جيش يسيطر على
السلطه في ذلك البلد بطريقه غير قانونيه
سيكون من المستحيل بم ان نستمر
بتقديم هذه المساعدات الامنيه نحن في
برنامجنا
ركزوا على المساعدات الانسانيه لشعب
النيجر وعندما يتعلق بالمساعدات الغذائيه
والمساعدات الانسانيه بالتاكيد نحن نحاول
ان نستمر بتقديم هذه المساعدات لكن هذه
المساعده ستتاثر لانه مع حدث في هذا بلد
بافعال غير القانونيه وعندما يكون هنالك
رفض للديمقراطيه التي تعب شعب النيجر من
اجل الحصول عليها ان نراه مغادره للقطاع
الخاص للبلاد ونرى اخلاء للسفارات هذا
الامر سيكون سيئا للاقتصاد ولشعب النيجر
ايضا ماذا ايضا عما يجري في السودان
شاهدنا في الايام الماضيه سجال بين ممثل
الحكومه السودانيه ومندوبه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لدى مجلس الامن ماذا عن
الملف السوداني
لديكم سيده سلمان
الوضع في السودان مدمر كان هنالك مطالب
شعبيه
قبل سنوات
وقد تم احباط هذه المحاولات كان هنالك
الشباب والشابات خصوصا الذين طلبوا نهايه
للدكتور للحكم الديكتاتوري ونهايه للقمع
هذا الجهد من اجل حصوله على حكم مدني كان
هنالك تم احباطهم من قبل انقلاب من قبل
الجيش السوداني لاشخاص وضعوا مصالحهم فوق
مصالح الشعب السوداني وكان هنالك ايضا
قتال بين فصيلين كل منهما يريد ان يسيطر
على السلطه بدلا من ان يكون هنالك تمكين
للشعب هنالك تقارير مؤثره للجثث منتشره في
مدينه الخرطوم حيث راينا ربما نرى انتشارا
للامراض والمستشفيات اغلقت في انحاء
البلاد وسافرت بقرب الحدود التشاديه
السودانيين الذين كانوا يعبروا الحدود
ولقد اخبرونا قصصا مروعه
لمعناه التي يعانوها وقصص مشابهه لباده
الجماعيه التي شاهدها الناس في دارفور وقد
تحدثت الى مسؤولين سودانيين ناشدتهم من
اجل ان يكون هنالك استمرار لتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه وتقديم الغذاء
والمساعدات الاجتماعيه لمنعانوا وتاثر
بشكل كبير نتيجه لكن بشكل اساسي ليس هنالك
حل انساني لما يحدث للسودان الامر يتطلب
وليسون الكحه العسكري يتطلب الامر من
الطرفين ان يلقي الاسلحه من الجنرال برهان
واحببتي ان يلقي الاسلحه وان يبداوا
بالحديث مع بعضهم البعض وان يضعوا مصالح
الشعب السوداني فوق الجميع هل تضغطون على
الاطراف
وباي وسائل
الامر مشابه الان لما يحدث للازمه في ان
نيجر الدبلوماسيه هي اساسيه كما هو الحال
بالنسبه لوحده المجتمع
الدوليه والفاعلين الاقليميين الذين
يؤثرون بشكل كبير في حالات السودان على
الفصيلين الذين دمروا البلد من الاساسي
بمكان انهم لا يكون هنالك تجهيز
لمساعدات عسكريه تمكن طرفا على الطرف
الاخر ما يحدث الوضع مروع لن يربح احد لن
يكون هنالك منتصر على الاطلاق والخاسرين
سيكونون المدنيين الابرياء وهذا حصل بدا
من هذا الامر يحصل من بدايه الحرب في
حقيقه الامر نرى هنالك
معاناه غذائيه ونحن نضع في برنامجنا
وبرامج اخرى من اجل توفير المساعدات
الانسانيه وتوفير شريان لكن
الاساسي هو الضغط الدبلوماسيه من اجل
اجباري الفصائل المتقاتله على الذهاب الى
طاوله المفاوضات وايضا الاقليم الضغط
الاقليمي الموحد هذا امر مهم من اجل
التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار وبعد ذلك
العوده الى خارطه الطريق التي ستاتي
بالحكم المدني للبلاد
مديره الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في اخبارنا الاخرى اكد البيان الختامي
لقمه دول المجموعه على ابقاء كل الخيارات
مطروحه على الطاوله لحل الازمه في النيجر
سلميا كما طالب بتفعيل القوه الاحتياطيه
للمجموعه على الفور
هذا ونقلت سجود عن مسؤولين غربيين قولهم
ان قاده الانقلاب هددوا بقتل الرئيس
المحتجز اذا تدخلت دول الجوار عسكريا وكان
ما يطلق على نفسه المجلس الوطني لحمايه
الوطن في النيجر اعلن تشكيل حكومه جديده
تضم واحدا وعشرين وزيرا
اعلنت الاداره العسكريه لمنطقه كوبيانسك
في مقاطعه خركيف بدا اجلاء السكان من
البلدات والقرى المحيطه وقال المتحدث باسم
الحرس الوطني الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
تحاول اختراق الدفاعات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
كوبيانسك في الاثناء نقلت عن مصادر
امريكيه مطلعه ان رئيس بايدن سيطلب اليوم
من الكونغرس مساعدات دفاعيه طارئه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 13 مليار دولار
يتطورات في السودان حيث قال مصدر بالجيش
السوداني للجزيره ان سلاح الجو اغار على
مواقع للدعم السريع بمنطقه حمره الشيخ في
شمال كردفان وفي منطقه الرياض الشرقي
مدينه الخرطوم وان الدعم السريع اطلق
مضادات الارضيه وفي الخرطوم بحري تصعدت
اعمده دخان داخل مناطق تمركز قوات الدعم
السريع بينما تبادل الجيش والدعم السريع
القصف في شرق ام درمان وقد نجحت عشرات
الاسر من المنطقه التي تشهد قتالا عنيفا
مستمرا منذ ايام
جلال ومياده وجوله منتصف الليل